Ya os avisamos que los viernes va a seguir habiendo Q&A aunque haya acabado la temporada 24-25 o más
o menos porque tenemos mundial de clubes, ya hablaremos del mundial suficiente la próxima
semana pero hoy este Q&A se va a centrar sobre todo en el mercado de fichajes.
Te pasa pizarritas ya estamos aquí los de siempre y como siempre de forma variadita y
picadita Adrián Blanco, Alex de Llano, Nahuel Miranda, ¿cómo estáis chicos? ¿Qué tal chicos?
¿Cómo estamos? ¿Qué tal? Muy buenas. Muy buena Cami, la de Adrián Blanco, el cual por cierto viene
siendo cada vez más elogiado por la creciente distancia entre un hombro y otro. Sí, sí, ya
hay cuatro euros de carrera de taxi que diría Alberto de Yogo, hay todavía seis euro. Ya hay
gente que se está empezando a plantearse cosas, que se está haciendo preguntas, preguntas para
los que quizás no tiene respuestas. Bueno, oye, abierto. ¿Hay algo ilegal ahí? ¿Hay algo ilegal?
No, de momento no. De momento no. Me gusta porque dice de momento. La cosa tira hacia adelante. No,
no, siempre natis, chicos, siempre natis. ¿Cómo que natis? ¿Puedo pegar ya el primer palo? Sí,
por favor. Creo que es de las peores camisetas del Levante que yo he visto. Sí, bueno. A todo
peor el Levante, pero es una camiseta cuestionable. Bueno, activamos el... A parte de Adrián Blanco,
así de grande, así de fuerte, parece Nikola Vuksevich. Sí, sí, sí. Te vas a trabajar, eh.
Activamos el contador de suegreos, van uno. A ver dónde acabamos. La media es prometedora. A mí me
mola, eh, porque siempre las camisetas del Levante me molan. El toquecito granota y no tan azulgrana
como Eibar Barca creo que queda muy bien con ese tipo de azulgrana. A ver, a mí me amaba porque el
Levante abrió su outlet y me tocó bien. No, no. Adiós. Adiós. Lo peor que te puede pasar.
Esto es lo peor que te puede pasar. Jaque mate. No me lo puedo creer, tío. No me lo puedo creer.
Bueno. Vamos a apañar esto como se puede. Además es que... Cago en diez, encima está lleno de polvos.
Las hierbitas del mate son aputadas, eh. Ay, qué putada. Se cuela por todos lados. La alfombrilla
está para limpiarla después. Nada, nada. Yo... Bueno, estaba diciendo... Sí, sí. No, pero no sé si empezar
o aflitarte mientras... A ver, puedes hacer dos cosas a la vez. Yo sé que te cuesta un poco eso,
Miguel, que es un reto profesional, pero... Tengo mi cámara aquí, ¿vale? Y os tengo vosotros ahí.
Entonces... Vale. Todavía... Mira, deja de mirarme un segundo y me tiran de la primera pregunta y
la tengo por texto, ¿eh? Me parece, me parece de bien. José BJ17 pregunta si creemos que la
flexibilidad de las normas del fairplay va a propiciar que más equipos tengan más posibilidades
de retener a sus jugadores clave. Recordamos que la liga ha cambiado alguna que otra cosita,
ha matizado alguna que otra norma, ha flexibilizado en resumen algún que otro criterio referido,
por ejemplo, a establecer un límite mínimo del 30% de la cifra de negocio, que a veces veíamos
alguna cifra rarísima, por ejemplo, del Sevilla, que dices que no tiene sentido, entonces lo han
dejado en 30%. Luego ha establecido algo que se llama... ¿Hadón Salto, no? No he entendido,
no he entendido, pero bueno... Vas a ver un mensaje que había petado la cámara y he tenido que
refrescar. Vale, vale, vale. No quería explicarlo, quería que pasara de puntillas, pero bueno, ya que
nos paramos de nuevo, esto está siendo muy complicado, ¿eh? Luego la liga ha creado algo que se
llaman como fichajes a cámara lenta, en el sentido de que permite inscribir a futbolistas con la
garantía de que luego, durante el año, se cree ese espacio salarial para realizar esa inscripción.
Y luego, por último, también la liga, y esto me parece importante porque quizás va referida a la
pregunta de José, la liga también ha reflexibilizado las reglas para renovar a jugadores menores de 24
años, incluso si el club no tiene espacio salarial, sino está en el 1-1. Es decir, que con esto los
clubes van a tener más facilidad para negociar según qué fichajes y también según qué renovaciones.
¿Cuánto va a permitir a los clubes retener su talento? Hombre, no creo que vaya a cambiar una
barbaridad, pero sí que es verdad, Zadri, que así quizás muchos clubes dejan de tener una posición
perdedora en el mercado. Esto es lo que veníamos criticando. No es que el límite salarial no fuese
justo, que eso, oye, son los criterios que establecen entre todos, los aprueba la liga, la liga son los
clubes, bien, parante, pero si solo la liga se establece con ese límite salarial y el resto de
ligas hacen un poquito, la mayoría, lo que les da la gana, pues deja en una posición, insisto, de
indefensión al fútbol español cuando luego acude al mercado común. Absolutamente, yo creo que dentro
de un control, que esto no se vuelva a alocar y los clubes se vuelvan a hundir dentro de las deudas
con la ciencia de la seguridad social, yo creo que en todo un control, creo que los cuatro somos
partidarios de que hay que flexibilizar un poquito la norma y que hay que tratar de ser un poquito
más creativos, un poquito más flexibles para dar un poquito más de margen en el mercado, es que si
no, del contrario, estamos viendo que cada vez que se abre el mercado de fichajes España se estaba
convirtiendo en un mercadillo. Es inevitable que venga un Brighton de turno, un Chelsea,
eso va a seguir pasando y se lo va a llevar. A veces que cobran de media cobran 100 kilos más que los equipos
españoles por los derechos. Y la masa salarial muchas veces, por ejemplo, hace que esa cláusula de
los jugadores, de los jóvenes talentos, no pueda ser todo lo que le gustaría, no se trata de poner
venga 100 millones de cláusulas, este joven talento que tengo aquí, tiene que ir acorde al salario.
Yo recuerdo a varios clubes hablar del modelo, no sé si me equivoco, el modelo alemán que
hacía esto en trienios, a la hora de calcular el tema del límite salarial o se hacía que los
clubes tuviesen cierto margen para tener un año quizás de ciertas pérdidas e inversión, pero que
en tres años se compensase. Creo que hay que controlar... Esto no era tanto el límite salarial,
sino que a la hora de hacer el reparto de los derechos de televisión se tenía en cuenta como
el ranking de UEFA en las últimas cinco temporadas, que por eso fue por lo que el Leipzig tardó tanto
en poder estar a nivel de gasto de los más grandes en Alemania. No podía hacerlo nada más subir a
un desliga. Luego lo que hace Alemania es con cada club hacer una auditoría todas las temporadas y
decide si le entrega la licencia o no, que fue noticia porque con el Schalke 04 hubo alguna
temporada donde en segunda división estaba complicado. Bueno vamos a ver qué impacto tiene,
pero sí que es verdad que se han flexibilizado ciertas normas en ese sentido y que creo que puede
ayudar al fútbol español a que en el mercado de fichajes oye se maneje de una mejor manera.
Fran J. Benitez 10 pregunta a Les De Llano por la posición que debe priorizar el Sevilla en
este mercado y aclara, si no lo teníamos claro nosotros, estamos flojos en todas. Hay que tener
en cuenta que está a puntito de llegar cordón. Nosotros estamos hablando de esto el miércoles
4 de junio 12 y cuarto, ya se ha anunciado la marcha de Víctor Horta. No sabemos exactamente
qué va a pasar con el entrenador, pero llegue cordón o no, llegue algo así o no,
llegue quien llegue. Alex, la plantilla es muy justita. La plantilla es justita. Obviamente yo
creo que a la gente el cuerpo le pedirá gol, le pedirá un tipo que yo se las tire y las marque.
Que me parece que Sol Sevilla no lo ha tenido esta temporada, ha tenido Luque Bakio, pero al margen
de eso, que habrá que ver si se termina quedando o no, que termina corriendo con su situación.
A mí si el entrenador es un estilo Imanol, pongamos que no es Imanol, pero se busca de ese estilo. A
mí ese equipo me parece que le falta un centro van pista de juego, o sea un pivote, pero aquí
a Lima. Yo te diría que esas son las que yo veo que podrían preocupar un poquito más. También entiendo
que se irá a Bade o que tiene muchas posibilidades de irse y ahí ya necesitas un central. Yo creo
que es un equipo que necesita muchísimas, pero yo te diría que para mí la prioridad sería en esas tres.
Yo te acuerdo con eso. Todas, todas, todas no hay que reforzar. Extremos no.
A mí la defensa me gusta. Bueno, dentro del contexto. Hay que ver qué pasa con Kike Salas,
hay que ver qué pasa con Loic y Bade, pero sí que es verdad que el tema del 9 me parece prioritario.
Es verdad que venimos de ver a Imanol Aguacil en la Real Sociedad no potenciar a los 9, pero no sabemos
qué es Imanol Aguacil fuera de la Real Sociedad. A mí lo del 9 me parece prioritario incluso por
encima del centro van pista. Yo creo que Agumé ha hecho un buen final de temporada y a mí es un
jugador que creo que hay que mantenerlo, que creo que está bien, pero hay que acompañarlo de un
jugador con buen pie. Esas serían las dos prioridades básicas, pero si tengo que poner,
si tengo 10 millones por hacerlo muy simplón. Adri, pongo 7 en el delantero y 3 en el centro
campista porque además el delantero va a ser más caro que el centro campista aunque tenga un nivel
más o menos parecido. Sí, es verdad que con Imanol hemos visto la doble punta, pero a mí me gustaría
ver una inversión de un 9 que pueda jugar con Isaac Romero para así, oye, igual matas dos pájaros
un tiro. Tienes un delantero que te haga los goles y un futbolista que potencia a su vez a Isaac Romero
como hacía en el sirio. Lo vimos alguna vez con Sorro C. Isaac, yo recuerdo un día en el
metropolitano de Sorro C. Isaac, pero vamos, contadas ocasiones. Sí, a ver, yo, esto lo hemos hablado ya
cuando estaba un Víctor Horta en el Cargua, a Sevilla le va a tocar ser muy creativo en el
mercado de fichajes, igual sería buena idea, seguro que lo estudiara Cordón, buscar sesiones
tipo Fabio Silvano en Deportivo a las Palmas. Es decir, yo voy a intentar pescar en futbolistas
que estén un poquito venidos a menos o jugadores jóvenes que traten de encontrar la oportunidad
buscar ese tipo de operaciones a las que sí puede acceder el Sevilla y no compras. Y a Core Adams
no nos tiene que demostrar más, no? Es que ha jugado a poco. Cuatro partidos, no? Hay que decir que Horta intentó esa
vía la que comenta. Has usado la pregunta pero tenías la respuesta preparada. Ha apuntado a Adri la vía de
la cesión de esos jugadores talentosos que además el Sevilla tiene mucho mercado, mucho más que la
mayoría de equipos que suelen pedir sesiones. Realmente lo intentó con Aníbal Meirri, salió muy mal
desde la primera semana y Loconga... Con Marco, con Beliz, uno del español de esta temporada.
A mí me ha parecido que no ha funcionado ninguno, salvo a Goume que creo que empieza cedido y luego
termina fichado pero es verdad, Nau, que es un tipo de refuerzo que necesita sobre todo en términos de
calidad neta, ¿sabes? Porque a lo que menos acceso va a tener el Sevilla ahora mismo es a calidad neta
pura y dura salvo que haya oportunidades de mercado como el de Vargas que a mí me parece que es un
fichaje de momento y que salió muy bien. A ver, el tema con ese tipo de cesiones es que si yo soy el
Manchester United, soy el Chelsea, soy el Tottenham, soy el PSG, igual quiero mandar a
jugar a un entorno más tranquilo, a un perfil más girona por ejemplo o en otro nivel lo que hace el
Mirandes en segunda división que no meternos en Sevilla, es que en Sevilla ya con el horno que no está
para bollos pues Meirri a los 20 minutos aterrizando en Sevilla ya estaba con la cruz puesta, es que no
tiene tiempo de crecer entonces yo creo que eso es complicado, el Sevilla ya lo está haciendo,
pues eso, ha fichado del United, ha fichado del Tottenham, ha fichado del Arsenal, ya se está
moviendo en ese sentido, fichó del Inter en el caso de Agumé pero la mayoría de ese tipo de
apuestas no la han salido porque al final son jugadores que están por hacer y lo que te pide
la situación es un jugador un poquito más resolutivo, un poquito más hecho a veces. Lo intentó con
Aledio Comadri también. Sí, pero bueno, complicado, complicado, igual es un triple que había que
tirar pero es un triple que no ha entrado, la pizarra de Bo, ¿vale? Bo, de Bo. Bo, Bo, Bo, Bo,
¿os acordáis de ese dibujo? Bo, Bo, por el poder del cabello nasal. Claro, claro, claro, que tiraba con los pelos de la nariz.
No, no, no, no lo vi, no lo vi. Mercado Villarreal, Mercado Villarreal, Alex, tenéis que elegir,
vale, es una especie de papá-mamá pero en este caso con desarrollo de mercados fichajes,
tenéis que elegir entre fichar a un central por si se va a Foyx el año que viene buscando el futuro
de la posición o un medio centro para buscar el nuevo medio centro posicional para cubrir ya la
futura marcha de Dani Parejo. ¿Por dónde lo tirarías tú, Alex? Yo por el medio centro,
creo que el tema del central se puede solucionar más con lo que hay, más la cantera, pero el
medio centro sí que veo que la figura de Parejo probablemente sea más difícil de llenar con
alguien que ya esté en plantilla o con alguien de la casa. Yo tiraría por el medio centro. Yo creo
que también. Yo creo que también tiraría por el medio centro, que no tiene que ser un medio centro
único que juegue por delante de la defensa, porque sabemos que Marcelino habitualmente juega con el
4-4-2 y tiene que ser una pieza que encaje en el doble pivote, así que yo buscaría un centro
campista que tenga criterio con balón y que pueda hacer ese relevo que ya está empezando el Villarreal
con Parejo. A ver, la información de los compañeros del delegado y de Javi Mata es que
Marcelino cuenta con que Foyt siga. Ya en una entrevista reciente se la tira ahí un poco para
decirle que queremos que seas un jugador, que seas un pilar de este equipo en los próximos años.
Entonces yo me despreocuparía un poco en ese sentido y centraría los esfuerzos en el tema del
medio centro, que ya el propio Marcelino dice que Parejo es de los mejores jugadores que yo he
entrenado, pero lo tenemos que dosificar y más una temporada con Champions. De hecho, Nao, es que
te diría que tú la apuesta por los centrales ya la has hecho. Que los bancos de Cambuela no nos
han encantado la primera temporada, no nos han encantado la primera temporada y hay dudas
legítimas con los dos de diferente tipo, pero bueno tienes que proteger tu inversión y tienes
que darle tiempo y esto es algo que el Villarreal sabe hacer muy bien. Y Pauna Barro, me imagino que
tendrá relevancia si ocurre ese escenario que nos dibujan. Lo de Pauna Barro es sobre todo lo que
es el lateral. Habrá levas de central? Sí, yo creo que sí. Yo creo que en la posición de Kiko
Femenia, que es otro de sus jugadores que va a dejar hueco. Y que termina siendo central a la hora
de salir, porque es verdad que defienden 4-4-2 el Villarreal, pero ataca con tres desde atrás,
como siempre explicamos. Hablaban por cierto de Cuenca, es del Villarreal, también del Barcelona,
cantenado de la Masía. Que el Rayo estaba interesado, porque en el full-on no había tenido
mucho impacto. Sería interesante esto, pero lo que iba a comentar es que has hecho esa apuesta,
la tienes que proteger, la tienes que cuidar. La cuestión es, en el centro del campo necesitas
alguien posicional. Eso creo que lo tenemos claro, porque tienes a Kome Sanya y a Puppet Gate, a los
que les gusta más volar. Son jugadores diferentes, pero les gusta tener recorrido. Estamos fijándonos
en el perfil parejo, es decir, un jugador posicional de un pie super dotado. Para mí,
Dani Parejo cuando sonó para el Barça de Valverde podía haber fichado por el Barça de Valverde
perfectamente. Estamos hablando del centro del campo del Barça. Igual, Marseíno, con la inseguridad
defensiva que ha llegado a tener su equipo, piensa en un jugador posicional, pero quizás de un corte
diferente. Lo digo sobre todo porque ¿cuántos Dani Parejos hay? Muy poquitos. Sin embargo,
si hay alguien que pueda acceder, es el Villarreal, que al final te vas a jugar a la corte en el 26.
Hay futbolistas como Rabiot, el que ya tuvo en Olímpico de Marsella. Ese perfil de futbolista
de hoy… Genduzki. Se molaría. Algo así. A mí me encajaría un Antonio Blanco, por ejemplo.
Mousi. Enzo Barrenechea para mí es un gran fichaje para Villarreal. Es que tienes opciones.
No me parece un mercado reducido. Claro, pero Barrenechea no es otro parejo. Es un jugador
posicional de otro perfil. Claro, pero yo me voy a eso, que es un jugador que tiene que guardar la
posición. Dani Parejo la guarda. Seguramente te hagan falta dos incluso. Sí, seguramente sí.
Y si quieres a un parejo, a sus 27 años, Rodrigo Bentancur… Chicos, el que ahí lo saqué del
trotteramo. El heredero de Guren. Hubiera sido gracioso porque el Villarreal en la cantera tenía
un jugador que acaba contrato, si no me equivoco, que se llama Rodri Alonso, que es como de los grandes
medioscentros de España. A uno le coges el nombre y al otro la apellido. En Nación Vadía, ¿no?
Rodri Alonso, Pereira García. Es una combinación parecida. Cuarta cuestión, Albert Cazorla. Esta
te ha gustado a ti, Adri, porque te he visto un montajito en Twitter. ¿Podría Jadon Sancho ser
el nuevo Anthony? Por favor, ojalá. Ojalá sea así. Me encantaría que lo fuese. Oportunidad de
futbolista por el cual el Chelsea está pagando para no quedárselo, que me parece tremendo.
Brutal. Si tiene mucho de clickbait lo de pagar para no quedárselo. No paga un fío. No te quieres
quedar a los jugadores, que no le quieres pagar lo que le paga el United. Son 250 mil por semana.
Estás dispuesto a pagar con tal de no hacer eso. No, es que te sale más barato. Claro,
es que pensémoslo así. 250 mil por semana es un millón al mes. Son cinco meses de contrato,
realmente. Es curioso, pero a mí me parece que Jadon Sancho ya tiene que dar ese paso. Es el
pasito atrás, Alex. Yo creo que con el Dortmund ya lo dio. No sabría decir que es el Chelsea en
este momento en el escalafón europeo, pero Betis, equipo de Europa League, equipo que juega bien,
equipo que te puede permitir reencontrarte contigo mismo. Yo creo que a veces los jugadores se pierden.
Mira, contador de estornudos. Lo que te decía Alex, que hay veces que el jugador se pierde y
que necesita volver a reencontrarse y volver a reencontrar su pasión por el fútbol. Yo creo
que esto es lo que le ha pasado a Anthony. Es verdad que Anthony desde el primer día llega con
esa mentalidad. Quiero darle mérito también al chico, no solo a Pellegrini, no solo a Betis,
no solo a la ciudad, a la afición. Quiero dar mérito al chico, pero es que aunque no hubiese llegado
con esa mentalidad, como que el Betis te empuja a ello. Y yo creo que Jadon Sancho necesita eso
para luego si acaso volver a dar un paso adelante. Sí, de hecho ya hubo un tiempo atrás en el que
Jadon Sancho dejó de jugar con el Manchester United para hacer una pausa, hacer un momento
de reset anivemental. Es verdad. Supuestamente Den Haag le ayudó, le dio unos contactos en Países
Bajos para que fuera a entrenar allí, entrenara en diversas sedes. O fue como los contactos en Países
Bajos para ir a relajarte. Sí, sí, sí. Cuando lo ha dicho… Yo cuando lo he dicho pensé que me iba
a decir, joder, le podría haber llevado a Dubai, que entrenara con buen tiempo, a Marbella,
a tal, a no sé qué, pero le llevó a… No, no, no, a Países Bajos. Pues yo que sé, en Países Bajos.
Que no es lo mismo los Países Bajos que los Países Bajoneros. No sé, serán los tulipanes quizás,
no? Era en Brabante, perdón, no, en el OJC Rosmallen. ¿Qué? Tócate, ¿eh? OJC Rosmallen.
¿Pero qué? En las instalaciones de ese club. Ah, vale. Ah, vale, claro, es que, joder, das un nombre
al puto Azahar. No, que eran las instalaciones de ese club en Brabante. El coffee shop en el que
estuviste en Ámsterdam, Alex. No, no, no. Es que era como la clave del wifi, tú. Sí, OJC Rosmallen,
Voetbal, un equipo amateur de Países Bajos. Vale, vale. Entonces, ¿ves lo del Betis? Bueno, sí,
que lo veo y además me encajaría que si hubiera interés del Real Betis, que todavía me imagino
que no, pero bueno, a ver cómo se da el mercado. Antonio diría, niño, Sevilla, ni te lo pienses.
Sevilla, pero igual en el verdiblanco mejor, porque en el otro están ahí como, no, está ahí todo muy
movido, igual ahí no te relajas, pero en el Betis con Pelegrini y tal sí que está. Aunque,
mi gran pedrada, chicos, mi gran pedrada, porque yo creo que esto ya sería confirmar el nivel de
resurrección del Betis, es Rahim Sterling. Ostras, hombre, a ver, creo que eso hay que
dejarse al Villarreal, que lo ha conseguido con Pepe más o menos, vale, incluso con Dan Juma.
Al Betis todavía le queda alguna etapa para lograr revivir a Rahim Sterling. Frank y Jen
siempre dicen lo de Joe Felix. Ostras. No me gano. Se ha enfriado un poco lo de Joe Felix a
Flamengo, que para el mundial de clubes, a mí me ponía cachondísimo eso. Hay que decir que las
bandas del Betis van a cambiar mucho porque tiene pinta de que Jesús se va a marchar, está el Rebel
Ice very cerca. A mí me sorprende, creo que es un movimiento algo temprano, algo temprano para el
chico. Pero bueno, es verdad que va a un sitio donde creo que puede culminar su desarrollo. O sea,
puesto a que la salida quizás es demasiado temprana, el lugar de desembarco no me parece
mal tirado y luego estaba el nombre de Brian Zaragoza, que parecía muy cerca de ocupar esa
banda izquierda. El Ice por cierto no lo hemos comentado, pero el trastazo de esta temporada
de ligas tremendo es que se ha quedado sin Europa y todo lo Red Bulls han quedado sin Europa,
en Austria afuera, en el Bragantino también. Sí, sí, desde luego. Por cierto, lo de Joe
Aho parece que lo que va a pasar es que va a volver al Benfica. Así? Es lo que están comentando.
Que no llegue el Mundial de Clubs a mí me… Lo digo porque me parece un poco frío. En teoría es por el
Mundial. Pero yo… Yo, vamos, yo estoy en ese barco. Pero de verdad os emociona todavía algo de
Joe Felix. Que sí, hombre, que sí. Es que te aburres muy pronto, Miguel. Las tres reacciones
hay que darles ahí un… Muy pronto, ¿no? Miguel es su hijo, ya tiene dos años, ya me he cansado.
¡Rosío, venga! Otro, otro. Muy pronto, es que creo que Joe Felix, hostia…
¿Joe Felix no te da pereza, Naúl? O sea, claro.
A mí no, mola. O sea, quiero decir, Joe Felix como ser humano da pereza.
Hombre, claro. Y como fotógrafo también. Pero la historia… Ostras, ¿te imaginas que con
la Benfica él hace bien? A mí me llama, me gusta. Lucía Gris pregunta. 150 millones por
Florian Birch no es una salvajada. Por muy bueno que sea que lo es. ¿Qué te parece, Naúl? 150
millones, que es la cifra que parece que está pidiendo el Bayer Leverkusen al Liverpool.
Una salvajada de Florian Birch. Es que Bellingham no cuesta mucho menos, ¿eh? Y creo que son
jugadores del mismo nivel, así que creo que el que los pague bien pagados están.
Tú siempre has preferido siempre a Birch antes que Bellingham.
Pero es una cuestión de gusto personal. A mí me parece que el nivel siempre se ha tirado
la comparación de los tres grandes talentos que pasaron por la Bundesliga, Generación 2003,
Bellingham, Mússila y Florian Birch. Y yo siempre he dicho que Birch a mí es el que más me… Es que
bueno, es que me encanta. Me flipa. Me gustan mucho los tres. Parece que tienen un nivel muy
parecido. Pero a nivel de gusto personal, el que más me gusta es Birch. Y creo que los 150
hace bien el Leverkusen en pedirlos porque se lo van a pagar. Y luego el tema de que el Liverpool
llevaba tiempo sin hacer una inversión así tan gigante. La hizo con Darwin.
Con Darwin la última. Sí, yo creo que fue un poco ahí Jurgen Klopp diciendo
oye, que me ha gustado mucho este tío. Venga, pum, pa'lante.
Claro, pero lo de Darwin era más una calentada. Sí, lo de Darwin olía calentada. Además de que
el cuerpo técnico de Jurgen Klopp tiene mucho lusófono. En el Liverpool tenía mucho lusófono.
Entonces, como el jugador del momento en Portugal, pues mira, venga, pum, te calientas y pones los 100.
Pero a mí me parece que esta sí que tiene sentido. Es verdad que yo creo que el Liverpool esta
temporada ha sido una máquina. O sea, ha tenido momentos de jugar muy buen fútbol. Probablemente
difuminado un poco el final de temporada dado el margen que tenía en Liga y lo que le ocurrió en
Champions. Pero aún así estamos hablando que poner a Birch dentro de lo que es este equipo,
yo creo que debería darle muchísimo. Y chicos, yo no sé cómo lo veis.
Es que a mí me encaja. En un centro del campo, Grabenberg, McAllister, Birch, es que me encaja.
Va a la media punta, ¿no? Yo entiendo que va a la media punta. Que por ejemplo, todos estos rumores
de Luis Díaz, etcétera y tal, yo creo que Birch está para jugar por dentro. Sí, llámalo media punta,
llámalo tercera altura, dependiendo cómo lo queramos dibujar. Pero yo creo que Birch es un
jugador de pasillo interior. Oye, y dominir con el que hay. A mí no me sorprendería que fuera el 9,
y que lo hará mucho. Todo lo ha hecho en el Valle del Veracruz. Al final tienes en banda tanto
Asalá como Agacpo, que son dos futbolistas que pueden hacer muchísimas cifras. Yo no lo descarto
ahí. No, pero yo tampoco lo descarto. Sobretodo porque es que Soboslay me parece buenísimo.
Lo que me parece importante es que juegue por dentro y que tenga libertad para participar. A partir de ahí,
que lo ubicas en banda de forma falsa como va en el Villarreal, para adelante. Que lo ubicas de interior,
más fácil. Que lo ubicas de falso 9, lo tendrás que compensar. Pero la clave es que es un jugador,
Adri, a mí de Bellingham, Musiala, Birch. No sé si me parece el más centrocampista,
porque seguramente el más centrocampista debería ser Bellingham, y creo que lo volveremos a ver con
Sabiallonso. Pero el más integrador es Birch. Es decir, el que hace jugar al resto. El que se
preocupa de que este pase, mejore la jugada y no solo sea una acción directa de cada gol. Ese
jugador con mentalidad de director de orquesta para mí es más Birch que desde luego Musiala y
Jude Bellingham. Seguramente de los tres también es el que más cómodo se encuentra jugando por
delante de la línea del balón a la hora de recibir, de ofrecer. A Musiala sí que lo hemos visto,
siendo un poquito más centrocampista y a mí no me gusta tanto. Si lo pueden ser los tres,
yo siempre lo que te comentaba Adri es esa faceta de el pase que parece que no importa,
pero es muy importante para ordenar al equipo. El que se preocupa de eso. Es un jugador que acelera,
es un jugador que tiene cifras como Bellingham, como Musiala, pero me parece que tiene esa labor
para ser ese... En Fútbol Manager estaba la posición de organizador adelantado. A mí me gusta y me
encaja mucho por lo que estáis hablando. Pero por contestar a lo que nos estaban preguntando,
150 kilos se convirtirían en el tercer fichaje más caro de la historia.
Yo creo que nos tenemos que acostumbrar ya a ver equipos Premier que les van a sacar todo y a
equipos que no necesitan vender pedir todo. Es que realmente yo creo que esta es la situación que
vimos en su caso con el Borussia Dortmund y con Bellingham. ¿Fueron 100 o 120? 120.
No, más. Bellingham con todos los variables eran 143. Se vendió que eran 113.
Yo creo que es más que lo que se publicó y que con los variables puede ver todo.
Y hay un detalle sobre el tema de Virts que a mí me...
Esto por cierto se sabe, esto no es información periodística,
sino que el Dortmund cotiza en bolsa y está publicado.
Como el Benfica, la operación también del Porto con Samo Morodion, de los plazos,
las cláusulas... Es que más claro no puede estar.
El tema de Milos Kerkes, que a priori es el objetivo de Liverpool para el lateral izquierdo,
que es una posición que entiendo que tienen que darle un poquito más de nivel, porque Robertson
bueno, poco a poco se está cayendo. Si en mi caso yo creo que nunca ha llegado a ser ese tío que
haya derrumbado la puerta y ha dicho yo soy el titular. Y Kerkes es un lateral de tanto recorrido
que podría cuadrar lo de Virts en izquierda cayendo mucho hacia adentro.
El Sergi Cardona Bahena que comentaba, esa posición falsa en banda para un lateral muy largo,
que igual ya es jugador del Liverpool cuando estáis viendo este Q&A, porque es cuestión de horas.
Me ha gustado mucho esta pregunta de Kenny Real Madrid, dice, todos los años existe ese
fichaje random que nunca sabes cómo pasa. Dice, teniendo toda la libertad, cuáles serían sus
nominaciones este año. Imaginaos un tipo Paul Pogba en el Zetafe, que así dicho suena a imposible,
pero claro, si te dicen a principio de temporada lo de Anthony por el Betis, lo de Alec por el
Leganés, lo de James por el Rayo, pues también nos hubiese costado pensarlo.
¿Y Pogba por Cardoso en el Betis, ya que hemos dicho de resucitar?
El Villamarín, que de hecho ya no va a jugar en el Villamarín en este plazo hasta la reforma,
tampoco es... no es Lourdes, sabes. Bueno, bueno, bueno. Cuidado.
Mucho milagro. Imagínate que de repente llega Fajardo y dice, mira, se acabó, vamos a hacer el
once milagro, y es todos los jugadores a los que tienen que resucitar la carrera.
Se va a montar Fajardo un vídeo de YouTube de estos que funcionan muy bien, resucitando jugadores.
Y él vestido en un chopeo, vestido con un traje, aunque siempre vaya en traje, pero chopeable.
Sí, tal cual. Pero ahí con la cabeza, un poquito más grande respecto al cuerpo.
Mira, venías hablando de Erickson en Clave Mallorca por aquello de, bueno, ser una opción,
también son ojumes en su día. A mí se me han ocurrido tres, ¿vale? Los doy en orden de porro,
y acabamos con el porro con uña, ¿vale? Porrito. Mijail Antonio, acaba contrato con el West Ham,
se fastidió la pierna a mitad de la temporada. Mijail Antonio al Getafe, porque me parece
un delantero, Getafe. Me encaja, me gusta. Lo abraza y se sube a él. Segundo, ya un porro
consistente. Vale. Chrisoviac, que acaba contrato, estaba en Chipre, en la Nortosis, por si os lo
estáis preguntando. Sí, primerísimo nivel. Al Levante Unión Deportiva, no sé cómo te suena, Adri.
Que vuelva Vuksevich. Y porro final, porro final. A ver. Robin Queson. A Leche. Porque,
porque patata. Porque me ha dado a mí, porque me levanta hoy, me levanta hoy y he dicho... Me
he puesto a pensar. Me he levantado pensando en Robin Queson. A ver dónde me encaja. La asociación,
he pensado en John Ghiietti, el delantero que juega al lado de John Ghiietti en la Suecia sub-21,
que gana la Eurocopa a la Portugal de William Carvalho, por cierto. Era Robin Queson y he dicho,
Queson, ¿a dónde? ¿Dónde me suena Rando? A Leche. Empaquetado. Muy bien. A mí, a mí me ha,
me está fastidiando el Milan. Me está fastidiando el Milan. Por Modric. Modric. Sí, porque Modric,
hace unos días, para el Getafe. Y eso sí que hubiese sido increíble. Pero increíble. Oye,
Lucas, te quedas en Madrid, no te tienes que mover. Y el pecho Tecno Casa.
Molarían el rayo. Aprende estas cosas que le calientan. También firmo, también firmo. También
el Milan. No mola, no mola. Yo, chicos, tengo un sueño. Vale. Espera, espera, espera. Cerrar los ojos.
Cerrar los ojos, chicos. Imaginaos, vale. Se viene cargadito, ¿eh, Alex? Este va cargado.
Se recomendó Eri Tejá ir a cierto club. Y me recomendó ir al OJC Rosmallen. Vale,
cerrad los ojos, ¿vale? Imaginaos. Ciudad de Valencia. Ostras, tal, primera edición,
vuelve tal, Julián Calero, ídolo de mansas, o sea, que se ha ido Carlos Álvarez, no han podido
retener. Pero empieza la temporada y el fichaje ilusionante es Gerard de Ulofeu.
Porque... Necesita recuperar su confianza. Porque visten de Blaugrana. Claro, está cerca de Río de
Arenas, ¿no? Medianamente, tal. Estaba entre el Levante y el Eibar, ¿no? Y...
Oye, oye, oye. Me ha gustado. Oye, parecidos, ¿eh? El pelusa de Ulofeu. Me ha gustado, me ha gustado.
Está bien tirado. De Ulo, por cierto, una de las entrevistas que más nos han gustado y más
sorprendentes que hemos hecho en las entrevistas. Muy crack. Tipo genial, de Ulo, la verdad, tipo genial.
De hecho, he buscado de Ulofeu en Twitter para ver si había salido algo de algún rumor y tal,
no sale nada. Pero lo primero que me salía era tal de la entrevista, de que la hicimos, o sea, un trocito.
Un trocito. No. A ver. Rodrigo Bentancur, ¿dónde? No, no, no, Rodrigo Bentancur, bueno, es que él
debería jugar donde quisiera porque es buenísimo. A ver, tengo dos y luego uno final para contentar a
Alex De Llano. Vale. Yo creo que a este le va a gustar. A ver, yo he decidido tirar del hilo de esos
fichajes que, bueno, que son un poquito exóticos y acaban triunfando y ejercen un efecto llamada.
Entonces, yo me he planteado que lo de la fengrúber en el elche ha ido tan bien que, claro, es que
a la gente que nos colgará el teléfono y dirá, oye, este inter que se descompone, oye, Marco Arnautovic,
no lo hemos visto en la Liga y que pueda ser el nueve del elche. Fan de Arnautovic. Para adelante.
Me flipa. De hecho, me cuadrarían en Sevilla, fíjate. Te compro Arnautovic en todos los equipos de la Liga.
Arnautovic, yo creo que tardaría 15 minutos en ser ídolo del sevillismo. Fenómeno, fenómeno.
Igual 30 en ser ídolo del veticismo. Marco Arnautovic tiene estas cosas. Me imagino cierto bajón en el
Mallorca diciendo, ostras, Samu Costa, dificilísimo que se quede. Pero, claro, Tacú Masano dirá,
chavales, no preocuparse. Mi primo Guataru Endo igual tiene ganas de venirse a la isla.
Mola, mola, mola. Y luego ya había pensado en juntar narrativas. Este es el de Álex.
Es evidentemente un fichaje para el Real Clube Deportivo Español. ¿Por qué he pensado en el
español? Se habrá dado mucho aquello de que el Arsenal es el equipo que más partidos ha jugado
de Champions sin ganarla Champions. Bueno, el español es el mejor equipo, la clasificación
histórica de la liga, que no ha ganado una liga. ¿Por qué no aspirar al hombre ganaligas por
excelencia que está sonando para salir de su equipo? ¿Por qué no pensar en que Antonio
Uroca va a ser suplente de Kingsley Coman la temporada que viene? Esto es mandarle el trocito
a Garagarza y que diga, ostras, cómo no lo he pensado. El año pasado tenías que rascar perras
para fichar a un ubar. No te preocupes, este año salto de nivel. Kingsley Coman, tú. Ahora
que decía Nauro de Arnautovic, estaba pensando, ¿no se habrá cansado de ganar ya pasta en Arabia
a Aleksandar Mitrovic y verlo aquí en España? Estaba pensando en Vallecas, pero claro, no sé.
Ve ahí alguna fricción. Yo creo que si se hace eso habría entrevistas a Zozulia esa semana.
Mitrovic ¿con quién podría...? Yo le veo en el Mallorca, por ejemplo. En el Valencia.
En el Valencia sería Bronco y Coppero. ¿Quién nos asuna? Está Budi. Sí, que por cierto,
se han publicado, claro, esto lo vas a ver el viernes, pero que por lo visto Budimir tiene
una cláusula de 20 millones, si no me equivoco. Tiene un periodo de días donde la cláusula baja
hasta, si no me equivoco, son 8 millones de euros. Tienes que estar atento al día. Claro,
sí, pero qué decir. En Pamplona ahora mismo están descontando días para el 7 de julio,
pero también para que acabe esa... esa ventanita, esa ventanuca. Mitrovic sería un buen 9 suplente
del Real Madrid, tanto que se ha echado de menos el perfil Joselu. 75, partido atascado y entra
Mitrovic. Lo de Budimir también me lo ha preguntado Iñaki en Radio Marca Pamplona porque se sonó
Real Madrid ahí en el entorno. Chicos, ¿y Cristiano? En el rayo, ya lo dijo su presidente.
Esto es como el elogiador del Fútbol Manager que le dices no tengo dinero, recomiendame a algún
jugador, Cristiano o Messi. Lo que molaría Cristiano y que diga Iñigo Pérez es que no me va
el central y al portero tiene que jugar Randy en Teca. Cristiano Ronaldo en el banquillo y luego
Edu Aguirre y el chiringuito llamando a Iñigo Pérez de todo. Si con James hubo editoriales y
Cristiano Ronaldo toca por lo que sea el banquillo de Vallecar. Mal entrenador Iñigo Pérez, la
temporada. La he dado mal. La he dado fatal. Se va la planta. ¿Os imagináis que Cristiano tiene un abuelo vasco?
Bueno, pero a ver, a ver. Sí, que sí, que no funciona así. No quiero herir sensibilidades,
era una broma, era un chiste. Humor. Así el arro, te quiero. ¿Sabes lo que ha hecho la Porth? Creo que
es que creo que ese segundo niño que tiene y los dos han nacido en la clínica que está en frente
de Samamés, que se ve Samamés desde la ventana. Ha hecho subió una foto ahí como con el con el
niño Samamés de Foda. Para que no haya ninguna duda. Eso pasa en Centenario también, que hay justo
detrás de, o sea, hay un hospital muy grande que da el Centenario. Tampoco vamos a abrir el
melón de la identidad del Atleti porque tiene evidentemente su sentido y como toda identidad
tiene sus puntos fuertes, sus puntos no tan fuertes. Pero sí que es verdad que me parece curioso que
un chaval, bueno, el caso de Iván Martín, que nace allí porque su padre se me dijo que era guardia
civil y ya está, pero no tiene más ligación a Euskadi ni en fase de desarrollo, ni culturalmente,
pueda jugar y un hijo de padres vascos que viven circunstancialmente en Madrid, por lo que sea,
no pudiera jugar. Este sería un tema para debatirlo con gente del Atleti, que es la que
de verdad tiene criterios para opinar, pero sí que es verdad que desde Foda me encajaría más lo otro.
Pero bueno, insistimos. ¿Para qué cambiar? De fondo lo que quiere la política es que exista un
sentimiento de pertenencia dentro del club y del equipo y no habría motivo para tocarlo. Pero
por eso te digo que creo que el sentimiento de pertenencia seguramente sea mayor entre un hijo
de dos padres vascos que un niño que nace en el mar y que están sus padres de veraneo. Yo creo que
lo que puedes desestabilizar es más que lo que puedes ganar con un cambio de opinión. En eso estoy
totalmente de acuerdo y en todo caso es un tema que no está cuestión, pero sí que me parece
interesante hablar de forma natural. Nos vamos al País Vasco, pero para hablar de un juego de
la Real Sociedad, porque un Gunermas dice entre Arsenal y Real Madrid, parece que va a fichar por
el Arsenal. No hablamos el melón de lo que puede ser o no. Es que ayer dijo algo que dejó ahí la
puerta abierta. Bueno, yo he escuchado la entrevista y creo que aún así nada. ¿Qué equipo es mejor
destino para Zoumendi? Imaginad que el Arsenal y el Madrid le quieren y que es Zoumendi el que
tiene que decir y va a decir por un criterio meramente deportivo. Pensando, dice un Gunermas,
tanto en mejorar equipo como en potenciar lo que ya es y pulir lo que puede ser. Yo creo que en ambos
sentidos, aunque creo que el Madrid necesita un jugador como Zoumendi, creo que en Arsenal encaja
más, que necesita más y que le puede hacer brillar más. Por una cuestión, no sé quién, qué aficionado
de la Real Sociedad lo dijo y me parece muy interesante y es un análisis que compro, Martín
Zoumendi es un futbolista que si su equipo naufraga no suma. ¿Qué dices? Hombre, pues como la mayoría,
tu equipo está naufraga. Pero que no lo rescata. Pero el Madrid necesita de su medio centro que
cuando se naufraga te rescate, que es lo que hacía Carlos Enrique Casemiro y que creo que es lo que
ha comenzado a hacer Chouameni por la capacidad física, la capacidad para abarcar metros, ir a
banda, ganar duelos. Zoumendi es un futbolista que te hace jugar mejor y que si juegas bien lo borda,
pero es verdad que en esos momentos de zozobra le cuesta un poquito más y creo que el Arsenal es
una balsa de aceite, entonces ahí Zoumendi la va a romper y el Real Madrid que es tendente a romperse,
a tener momentos de dispersión táctica, pues me parece que no encaja tanto. Entonces me quedo con el
Arsenal por esa razón que se lo leía a una aficionada de la Real y me parece que quedó en el clavo.
Es una buena lectura. Yo diría al Madrid, y a el Madrid por la necesidad que tiene el Madrid y
porque el propio Zoumendi ha reconocido que Xavi Alonso es el entador que más partido le ha sacado
y es de que Xavi Alonso haría de Zoumendi un futbolista mucho mejor de lo que ya es.
O sea, ¿tú crees que podría mejorar Zoumendi respecto a lo que hemos visto?
Sí, sí, sí, creo que Zoumendi todavía tiene margen de crecimiento, sí, sí.
Es un jugador que todavía no está cerca de su madurez.
Ya, a ver, bueno, son 26 ¿no? Si no me acuerdo mal.
O sea, los 30 que madure como centracampista.
Es que si la pregunta es...
¿Qué le conviene más a quién, no?
No, no, no, quiero decir, es que si no es Zoumendi, tampoco...
Quiero decir, a mí Stieler me gusta, pero tendrías una duda muy parecida a la que tienes con Zoumendi.
En el caso que ponía Miguel de, oye, si el equipo no ha frágalo va a conseguir rescatar el solo.
Hombre, es que hay que ser muy bueno y creo que ninguno de los que suena para el Real Madrid
ha demostrado estar a ese nivel, aunque muchos yo creo que pueden llegar a serlo.
A ver, yo sinceramente el tema del Arsenal lo veo que casa muy bien
porque el Arsenal necesita que su medio centro sume en las dos direcciones
y creo que Zoumendi suma.
Me parece que la Premier le puede venir muy bien por tema de ritmo, etcétera y tal
y por cómo él es capaz muchas veces de controlar los partidos.
Y yo sinceramente compro el análisis que compartías tú, Miguel.
O sea, me parece que quizá en el Real Madrid Zoumendi pueda
naufragar más de lo que va a naufragar en el Arsenal.
Yo creo que en el Arsenal sí que puede evolucionar un poquito más.
A lo que voy es que Zoumendi es un jugador muy de orden, que lo crea, le viene bien,
le sienta bien y el Madrid, aunque con Saga Alonso seguramente gane en orden
porque ganar en desorden es complicado, pero el Madrid es tendente al caos.
Salvo en la etapa, yo sé muy riñón, el Madrid es un equipo que fomenta el intercambio de posiciones,
que deja distancias entre líneas, que suele jugar...
Pero cuántas veces, Miguel, cuántas veces hemos dicho aquello de oye,
que el Real Madrid intenta fichar al mejor jugador disponible y luego ya verá cómo lo apaga.
Yo creo que es Zoumendi.
Bueno, no, yo es que no creo que sea Zoumendi.
O sea, sí, sí.
Bueno, a ver...
No va a fichar a Vitinha.
No, claro.
No va a fichar a The Clan Rai, no va a fichar a...
A Rodrigo.
No va a fichar a Enzo, no va a fichar a Rodrigo.
Pero el Madrid no ficha al mejor jugador disponible, ficha al que cree mejor
y si no le puede fichar, no ficha.
Porque es lo que ha pasado con Lenny Yoroh, mismamente.
Y estoy convencido...
Fichaba, fichaba, eh.
Bueno, sí, hay que ver qué pasa con el Centro Campista,
pero hasta la fecha, Tretales and el Arnold es el que consideran generacional.
Hausser, ahí sí que puedo tener cierta duda si lo consideraba o no
por el futuro de Saliba y tal, pero a mí me parece un pepino.
Y luego el tema de carreras, es verdad que puede ser un poquito más circunstancial,
pero bueno, es que a mí me parece que la política del Madrid
era muy extrema en ese sentido, así que yo estoy a favor de que se flexibilice.
Pero a lo que voy es que o ves muy claro el encaje de Zoui Mendy
o no fichas a Zoui Mendy por el nivel.
No sé si me explico.
Al hilo de lo que decías,
esto de si el Madrid no fraga,
no sabemos si Zoui Mendy conseguirá rescatarlo en esos momentos o no,
a mí algo que invita a ser optimista con Zoui Mendy
es que me parece un gran ganador de duelos, un tipo muy competitivo.
A pesar de la estatura, que no es tan alto como Rodríguez,
creo que sufre muy bien y que va muy bien al choque y es fuerte en ese sentido.
Me crees una absoluta gilipollita.
Y que luego él ordena mucho a los demás.
Se maneja mejor en el orden que el caos.
Bueno, no todos, no.
Yo creo que, por ejemplo, Fede Valverde se maneja mejor en el caos que en el orden.
En todo caso.
Pero ¿por qué?
Porque en el orden va cortito.
Te quiero decir que al final hay muchos,
yo creo que hay bastantes centrocampistas así.
De hecho, Chua Meni también me parece eso.
Que yo traía al Madrid a Zoui Mendy.
O sea, no significa que yo no lo ficharía.
Digo que es un ganador de duelos, pero desde el orden,
no desde las distancias cortas, desde la lectura.
Luego es muy bueno.
Al estar expuesto, al quedar muy expuesto.
Yo he visto al medio centro del Real Madrid permanentemente tener que cubrir al lateral.
Sabia lo que se pasaba a la vida cubriendo al lateral izquierdo a Marcelo.
Y antes cubrían a Roberto Carlos y a Casemiro.
Le hemos visto más a Taquensembanda que en el carril central.
Entonces, igual que el Madrid suele ser más de centrales optimistas que pesimistas,
porque suelen ser Militao, Sergio Ramos, Pepe y tal,
pues creo que en el caso del centro del campo también le viene mejor eso.
Y creo que es que el Arsenal es que le viene y que pintar.
Es que para mí el match Arsenal-Zoui Mendy es un 100%.
El de Zoui Mendy y Real Madrid que es un 80-85%.
Entonces, por eso lo veía más.
Siguiente cuestión de Arnaldiño.
A ver.
¿Cuál es vuestra historia de fichaje favorita de la Liga en los últimos años?
Historia de fichaje.
Vale, no el fichaje en sí, sino que el run-run, la razón...
Hombre, a ver...
Es que yo tenía fichaje como tal.
A mí la historia, yo creo que hay una que es insuperable,
que es la cesión de Joaquín al Albacete por un día.
Bueno, es algo que no se produce.
Bueno, le cedieron... Estuvo un día.
Historia de fichaje.
Es una historia de fichaje.
Oye, cedieron un día al Albacete.
A mí me gusta mucho la historia del arco de redención de Isco.
De... No sé, acaba como acaba en Sevilla, no firma por el...
Joder, el...
Unión Berlín.
Unión Berlín, gracias, que me salía Mainz.
No sé por qué.
El Unión Berlín.
Y luego tiene esa entrevista con Ochoa en Marca,
donde muestra que tiene un cambio de actitud.
Y luego, yo me acuerdo de decirnosotros en la pizarra.
Bueno, está muy bien decir esto,
pero luego es más fácil decirlo que demostrarlo.
Y lo de... Adriel y yo confiamos, eh.
Adriel y yo confiamos.
No, si queremos confiar, queremos confiar siempre, pero es verdad.
No, no, una cosa es confiar y otra cosa es confiar.
Habría que...
Habría que... Habría que...
Habría que repasar porque tu historia...
Nada, nada, nada.
Adriel Blanco se acuerda, tú te acuerdas.
Yo tengo tuits, eh. Yo no soy sospecho de sobrano.
Cuidado, cuidado. Tu historia con Isco al arco
no es demasiado agueño.
El único malo que he hecho es que no lo llevaba a la selección.
A mí me flipa, pero es que...
Pero te gusta agarrarte a eso. Luego a la hora de confiar...
Ayer... Luego a la hora de confiar...
Nao, Nao, Nao, juega conmigo.
La que confiaba, Quintana lo confía.
Nao, juega conmigo, juega conmigo.
Bailad.
O sea, juega conmigo, ¿vale?
Nao, cierra los ojos.
Cierra los ojos, vale.
España-Francia, se ha jugado ayer.
Minuto 75.
Tal partido ahí como en tierra de nadie. 1-1, eh.
Ha marcado Yamal.
Y ha marcado Dembele.
¿Eh?
¡Ostras! ¿El balón de oro?
Sí, el calcinismo con el balón de oro.
Cierra los ojos, cierra los ojos.
Eres Luis de la Fuente.
Echas la vista atrás.
Sí.
Ves en el banquillo a varios futbolistas.
¿Le llamas?
Le llamas sin abrir los ojos, eh.
¿Le llamas o no?
¿Le llamas?
¡Coño, la serpinillera ya!
Déjate de hostias, hombre, el vendaje.
Me gustaría tu formatín de entrenador del FIFA en TikTok, eh.
A los rudagonis.
¡Rudagonis, te quiero!
Eres un crack.
Crack.
Ahora ha salido uno del Mirandés, pero claro.
Al lado de rudagonis, pues chungo.
¿Ves a Isco?
¿Crees que Isco ha llegado a la fiesta?
¿Crees que Isco ayer fue clave ante Francia?
Déjate el pelito, hostia ya, Isco.
Venga, vamos.
No, no lo creo.
Por Dios.
Por Dios que haga una ruleta dentro del aire y la ponga a las cuadras.
No, no, el tema es...
Si al final no pasa, ¿qué hacemos?
Porque al final, claro...
Yo he ido a por la opción de...
Oye, no va a hacerlo bien.
O sea, vamos, va a ser uno más.
Tú me has dicho, cuando hay que confiar, ahí estamos confiando.
¿Y no has confiado?
No confía.
No, no, tú confías ahora que...
Que era la selección.
Cuando estaba en el ostracismo, confiamos a Adrián Blanco y yo.
La verdad, para ser decisivo en España-Francia...
A ver, ni el huyendo.
No lo veo.
A ver, yo...
No lo veo la selección.
No lo veo.
Entonces, ¿qué pasa?
Yo he sido la opción con la cual...
Pongamos que sale y que lo hace de puta madre, que ojalá.
Claro, es que va a venir la gente a pegarme la turra,
pero cuando pasa al revés, nadie lo va a reconocer.
Entonces...
Ya está.
Bueno, chicos...
Yo confío en el fichaje y en el partido de Azteca o Azteca ante Francia como titular.
Hombre...
Bueno, lo otro.
Como falso nueve.
Historia, historia favorita de fichaje.
Historia, otra.
A ver...
¿No os parece bonita la historia de cuando Rudmar Nistelrooy
vino a retirarse de nuestro país jugando con el Malaga?
Pensaba que había marcado más goles.
Cuatro en Liga, cinco en total en la temporada.
No, no, pero a favor, bonita.
Pero bonita.
Para mí es insuperable la de Rammel Falcao en el Radio Bécano.
Además, en la presentación no se escuchaba Falcao.
De la...
Por el micro, por la cantidad de pitos que había hacía presa...
En fin, creo que para mí es insuperable.
A mí, a mí y de los últimos tiempos, la de Julián también me parece tope.
Jugador que muchos creíamos...
Bueno, pero ¿cuál es la historia del fichaje?
¡Coño!
La historia es...
Parece humo.
Simeone llamando, Nahuel Molina llamando, De Paul llamando,
el otro diciendo que solo quiere ir a jugar a Atletico Madrid.
Coño, me parece una historia guay.
Hombre, si termina pasando lo de que en el sofá
donde jueguen un equipo en Madrid,
yo creo que va a ser muy parecido a lo que has resumido tú.
Pero...
En Argentina dicen que ella tiene una casa...
Las historias de fichajes que molan son un poco rocamolescas,
como lo que decía Adri de Joaquín y de Albafete, ese tipo de cosas.
Yo me tocó cubrir en su día...
Lo ha dicho Adri.
No, no, lo ha dicho él.
Ya nos confunde hasta Nahuel.
Ha dicho Adri, lo ha dicho él.
Bueno, pido perdón.
Yo me tocó cubrir en su día el doble no fichaje de Rodrigo Cayo
por el Valencia y por el Atletico de Madrid
con 20 en vestiendo caña.
Esas son unas historias que molan.
Pero claro, son historias de no fichajes.
Paul López, Paul López.
Claro.
Es que eso es una buena historia de fichajes.
Cabe Milito al Madrid y luego al Barça.
Claro, pero si estoy de acuerdo...
Andrés Gómez, portada del Marca con la camiseta del Madrid
y el día siguiente firmando con el Barça.
Pero a ver, a ver.
La pregunta es ¿cuál es vuestra historia de fichaje favorita?
No de no fichar.
Brian Ruiz, Brian Ruiz al Levante.
No llegó el fax.
Puto fax.
La comadreja.
Yo entiendo que es la historia en sí, ¿no?
De cómo se envuelve la incorporación.
Pero tiene que culminar.
Bueno, no, eh.
Igual está nervioso, igual ha tenido una mala noche
y no puede culminar.
Me quedo con otra de Simeone siendo agente encubierto,
la de Luis Suárez, por el Atleti.
El Barça le da la patada y...
Pues sí.
Nada, nada, nada.
A la suegra no.
Nada.
Incluso con Suárez.
Si se consuma, a la suegra no le mola.
Vaya.
Cavani al Villarreal y al FC Valencia.
Mira, una de Atletico Madrid, la de Moise Quén,
viendo el partido en el palco y dijeron
oye, Moise, a tomar por saco, que al final no.
Es que esas cosas son las que molan, hombre.
Mira, Kais, Vcf, hablando de cosas que molan.
Vamos a hablar de Ron.
¿Creéis que la entrada de Ron Gurley,
como nuevo CEO de FC Valencia,
traerá cambios en lo deportivo
o impactará especialmente en los fichajes?
Nau, ¿qué te dice a ti el olfato, el instinto?
Bueno, que ha habido 11 cambios a nivel directiva
en 11 años con Meryton.
No nos han dado muchos argumentos
para pensar que este va a ser un buen momento
o que este va a ser de algo.
Hay algún motivo para la esperanza,
el tema de que Ron Gurley ya estuviera involucrado
en el tema de la llegada de Corberán,
el tema de que sea un directivo de fuera de la órbita de Singapur.
Hablan bastante mal de su papel en el fútbol inglés,
también en el gilal.
Agilano Alagli, perdón, de Arabia Saudí.
Yo creo que es un monigote
para poder proteger un poquito a nivel público a Corberán
en un verano donde parece tener un poquito más de peso
a la hora de tomar decisiones,
que es algo que siempre ha debilitado a todos los entrenadores de Valencia
el tema de la relación con Singapur.
Es una figura un poco...
Yo diría que siempre se la ha relacionado
no tanto con lo que pasa en el césped,
sino con un poco el tema de marca,
el tema de impacto internacional, etc.
¿Pero el rollo mativo alemán te refieres?
No, no, no, para nada.
Es como...
Es un rollo como lo de Damia Vidagain, un poco.
Vale, en el bil.
De haber empezado en otras áreas,
él me parece que es un área más enfocada en el marketing,
y luego, al final, llevas tanto tiempo en los clubes
que acabas haciendo un poco de todo
y pasas un poquito más a la parcela deportiva.
Sí, él siempre ha sido feo
hasta cuando no sabíamos lo que quería decir feo.
En 2009 empezó en el Chelsea...
¿Nació feo?
Sí, señora, ha tenido usted un feo, ¿no?
Hombre, no fue un parto natural,
fue por Ceosaria.
¡Joder!
Duro este, eh, Nau.
Duro, duro.
Pero, a ver, yo creo que
tiene Nau mucho de cierto en lo que probablemente sea un buen nigote.
Y la verdad es que
todos los nomes...
O sea, tú buscas Ron Gurley en Twitter
y todo es este cabrón se ha cargado la marca de Alaphly,
se ha cargado al Westbrom,
al Chelsea...
El Chelsea...
El Redding...
Hay pocas propiedades peores que
la de Peter Lim, eh.
Pero lo del Redding...
A mí es que el tema de que lo de Corberán
sobre todo no es ya
el cambio de entrenador,
sino pagar lo que se paga por Corberán
además de lo de Baraja
y traer a Corberán
que no es...
O sea, no es el movimiento más sencillo.
El movimiento más sencillo igual hubiese sido que Sergio,
por ejemplo, que también estuvo...
Kike.
Exacto.
Eso me hace ser
mínimamente optimista,
sobre todo porque para mejorar
lo que hay, tampoco hay que ser
aquí... Pues mira, Mateo Alemáin,
o no, o Damien...
Pues, yo
querría serlo, pero hasta que el Valencia de Méridón
demuestre lo contrario,
pues seguirá siendo sospechoso.
Y ya estuvieron juntos en el Westbrom y tal,
a ver cómo sale.
Última pregunta, la única que no es sobre
un poco el verano, el mercado de fichajes,
pero es de actualidad.
Xavi17
nos pregunta,
¿qué os parece que perdamos a Luis Suárez para el
playoff? Cosa que de otra forma
diferente ya pasó con el
Real Zaragoza, ese mítico
Real Zaragoza que me dio muchas alegrías
el fútbol manager, porque
acabó el contrato, básicamente,
acabó la cesión porque era el año de
la pandemia y demás.
¿Cuál es vuestra opinión?
Porque claro, es una
jodienda. Yo cuando lo leí me pareció
que a mí, como quien dice,
me da igual. Y si me importa un poquito,
me gustaría ver a lo bien en primera división, la verdad,
porque tengo buenos amigos y porque me gusta la historia.
Pero me da igual quién suba, esa es
la realidad. Pero, hombre, que la Almedía
pierda a Suárez, luego también me dio
por pensar, la Almedía ya sabe
que puede perder a Suárez en la ventana de
junio. O sea, cuando
a un biche le tiene, es algo con lo que
tiene que contar.
Pero bueno. En Almería
tenía una plantilla para subir directo.
Claro, claro.
Cuando tienes a fútbolistas
de valor internacional y no
haciéndoles de forma directa, te van a pasar todas las cosas.
Lo que también me dio por pensar
que, ostras, es que acaba
muy tarde la segunda división.
Acaba muy tarde, es que es eso. Puedo entender
que buscas una ventana de exposición.
Mira, como los play-offs de la Liga CB, que
comenzaron el pasado lunes. Han empezado ahora,
en parte porque, bueno, está
Roland Garros y tal, pero
hasta el Mundial de Clubes no hay como
un gran foco futbolístico que
quita brillo el resto de deportes. Bien,
venga, lo puedo entender con los play-offs de la CB, que a más
empiezan bastante tarde. El calendario del
básquete es diferente. Pero
lo de la segunda división
es que porque le ha salido bien al español este año.
Pero, coño,
ascender tan tarde...
Hombre, al español
el año pasado se le vino a ver
la Virgen porque no convocaron a
Kady Bari y a Martin Braithwaite a la Eurocopa.
Por ejemplo. Si no hubiera tenido un caso
elevado al cuadrado.
Yo lo que creo es que
no puede ser que la Liga Inglesa,
que es Champions, que tiene más equipos,
que es verdad que el calendario de Champions
es matador.
O sea, es que has perdido un partido y
a los tres días tienes otro, y a los tres días otro.
Es como jugar competición.
Cuando se habla de las cosas que se hacen mejor en Inglaterra,
hombre, es que las jornadas entre semanas
coincidan siempre con las jornadas de Champions.
Muchísimo foco
y la jolienda para todos los que
quieran viajar fuera. Claro, pero eso
se puede hacer si acaso en Inglaterra,
porque al aficionado del Charlton lo que haga
luego el Chelsea en la Champions se la repampea.
Se la repampea. Infla pero lo más grande.
Sí, sí, tal cual. O sea, no
quiero decir que al aficionado X
es una división de importe. Pero si vamos a ver
en España hay mucha tendencia
a que te importe uno de
los tres grandes. Claro, estamos viendo
un repunte que me parece precioso
en ciudades,
en provincias, de
reclamar lo propio. Suele ser un
acción-reacción, ¿no? Es una contra
reacción a un mundo cada vez más globalizado
donde los equipos
cuatro, cinco, seis tienen
muchísimos aficionados y tiendes a lo local.
Me parece precioso, pero seamos honestos.
De los veinte mil que pueden ir
a X estadio, bueno,
o diez mil, hay un porcentaje
treinta por ciento, cuarenta por ciento, que
también son de otro equipo. Esa es la realidad
de nuestro fútbol. Nos parezca mejor o peor, pero
es la realidad. E igual dicen
coño, voy a ir en octubre a este partido,
me quedo en casa, veo la Champions
por la tele, a mi otro equipo y
patapún. O sea, esto puede pasar.
Pero a lo que íbamos con el tema Luis Suárez,
yo, si fuese una ventana de selecciones
de febr... de marzo,
de octubre, septiembre, ahí te fastidia.
Pues no tengas internacionales, ya lo sabes.
Pero la de junio, me parece que está puesta
a destiempo y me parece que
para la segunda división, ostras,
es una complicación tremenda.
Pero igual...
Siendo esto cierto, siendo esto totalmente cierto,
no debería mediar el propio Luis
Suárez. Yo también lo pensé.
Pero... no, pero...
vamos a ver una cosa. O sea, cómo va a ser
más importante jugar con la Almería que jugar con Colombia.
O sea, es que... ¿Qué no va a jugar?
Y Colombia ya está dentro
del mundial. ¿Pero qué es la selección?
O sea, es que ya está.
Con la selección va a estar toda la vida.
Con la Almería ya veremos si juega la temporada que viene.
Bien, pero en ese caso yo se aparte de que
la Almería le puede decir, muy bien, pues aquí
medio kilómetro. Claro.
Si no va a estar en el partido decisivo de la temporada,
medio kilómetro. No, no, no.
No haber bajado a la segunda división.
Tú cuando me firmas estás en primera. Si has bajado,
encima no te has metido en ascenso directo
y tienes que jugar un pleo.
Para que hubiese metido más goles de Luis Suárez
para centerme directo. No haberte ruido la pierna,
no, a ver. ¿Quién te manda a romperte
el día que marcas el hat-trick contra el club?
Oye, pero jugar con la selección
siempre tiene que primar por encima de jugar con el club.
Now, now. Vamos, de una manera indiscutible.
Es que sale Luis Suárez
contra Perú y marca dos goles
y es el nuevo titular de Colombia.
Y eso repercute en beneficio económico
también para el club. Pero una cosa no,
para empezar. Si Luis Suárez selecciona en el parón de ahora,
el Almería se lo come y no lo vende en verano.
Para empezar, yo entiendo el tema sentimental.
Ahora bien, esto también es un negocio
y el que te está pagando es la Unión Deportiva Almería.
Que la fecha FIFA está programada
y ya está, pero yo sí que entiendo
que, coño, te llaman porque
se lesiona...
Coño, el ex del Dortmund...
Borré, Santos Borré. Ah, no, el de
Eintracht. Sí, el ex de Eintracht.
Santos Borré, coño,
para no jugar
posiblemente te pierdes...
Pero que aparte tú no te puedes negar
a ir con la selección.
Claro, claro.
Fermín, Fermín,
no se ha negado a ir con la
Sub-21, pero la Sub-21
ha quitado a Fermín porque posiblemente
con un poco de sentido, porque
lo contrario, no tenía ningún sentido,
habrán hablado Barça-Fermín Federación
y han dicho, coño, después
de parón de selecciones y de esta temporada
me vas a meter en una Eurocopa Sub-21 a un
jugador que le han subido uno.
Pero al Barça le da igual.
Quiere decir, prefiere que no juegue tanto,
pero no le va bien a ello. Almería sí, almería se
está arrastrando. O me deja suares,
que es la estrella de mi equipo,
o cuál es el escenario que puede
contentar almería. No existe.
No existe, sino que suares se quede.
Que no le llamen, que llamen a otro.
Ya, ya. Y Colombia dirá, oye,
pues yo llevaré a los mejores porque yo quiero competir.
Claro, claro.
No, no, si ya, pero ostras.
Es fastidiado.
El tema es que, que yo
no lo digo por vosotros,
pero en torno a estos temas se hace de menos
a menos el fútbol de selecciones. Y para mí
es que es el más importante. Insisto,
insisto. Pero porque no pagan el sueldo
a tal. Es que es como si
de repente pues tenemos que
grabar un vídeo de... Bueno, pues cambiamos.
Y le dices a mi al pintana que no,
que se peine, que te vas a...
Yo que sé, a...
Que cambiamos. A montar el
Sport. Se puede plantear
que se cambie el modelo y tal y cual. Tal cual está montado
ahora.
Pero yo creo que en algún momento la Liga
tendrá que reflexionar y decir
oye, es que igual el calendario de segunda
división está mal planteado, sobre todo porque yo
creo que la segunda que no parara
en el parón de selecciones, me parece
que podía tener sentido. Yo solo compro.
En cuenta a principios de los 2000. No, pero yo
lo compro ahora también, eh. Lo paro.
Pues yo creo que ahora a los clubes
y a los directores deportivos les quitas
opciones. Pero no puede, pero no puede.
Ya, pero no puedes desperdiciarlo porque luego
el director deportivo quiere dinero de las teles
y estoy convencido que las audiencias
de la Liga Hypermotion son superiores en esos
parones respecto a los otros. Al final se trata
de encontrar... No, y cuando, escucha, y cuantas veces
hemos leído en prensa la típica noticia
de prensa local que sigue un equipo
en específico y que dice
eh, pues el Valencia muy atento
a la Eurocopa que puede hacer mamar
Dasvili para sacar más pasta. Es que
el fútbol de selecciones revaloriza a tus jugadores.
Es que, quiere decir, el tema del prejuicio económico
no es nada un monto válido. Pero la Eurocopa
no coincide cuando Valencia está a fondo es la permanencia.
Claro, claro. Bueno, pero
es lo que decía
Alex antes, que, eh, Bright White
igual pudo haber ido a la
Eurocopa y no fue.
Y vamos, estoy convencido que no lo llamaron.
Y si el marco ha llamado al español, pues
al español le dan por saco. Si independientemente
de que sea más importante o no, se trata
de crear un calendario
o un contexto para evitar este tipo
de situaciones. Yo creo que a la Liga no es así.
Es culpa de la Liga.
No culpa de Colombia o de la selección
de turno. Eso estamos todos de acuerdo.
Pero lo que ha dicho Adri, que tampoco es una barbaridad,
es que coño, que podría
intentar mediar para solventar
la situación, porque lo hemos visto mil veces.
Mil veces. Mil veces y con mil
jugadores. Llaman a jugadores que se saltan
convocatoria. No jodamos. Es importante.
En todo caso, que como
eso no va a cambiar en el corto plazo,
yo creo que ahí lo interesante sería que la Liga
adelantase en los playoffs.
Pero ¿qué sucede? Que yo creo que
la Liga echa cuentas y dice
vale, si, pierde la almería Luis Suárez,
pero yo aún así gano esta ventana de exposición
y me compensa. Igual que
el que asciende más tarde tiene menos tiempo
para planificar, pero a mí me sigue compensando.
Entonces, bueno, también te digo,
vuelvo a decirlo de siempre, la Liga son los clubes.
Entonces, si los clubes no aprueban
el calendario, el calendario no va.
Entonces, luego, lo digo
sobre todo por el aficionado. El aficionado si se quiere
quejar, que se queje también de la Liga de Tebas,
se me parece fantástico, pero que también se queje con su
propio club, que luego está aprobando
esas cosas que le van
a fin de cuentas en superjuicio.
Pero bueno, es un tema complicado.
A mí lo que me parece es una puta. Muy complejo.
Una puta, independientemente de quien tenga la responsabilidad
y la culpa, que igual no la tiene nadie, igual son las circunstancias.
Y punto.
En todo caso... Y por cierto, lo hemos
enterado mucho en lo de Luis Suárez, pero Pubil en principio
estaba convocado también con la Sub-21.
Sí, sí, sí. Y Ruby,
vamos, no sé si ha cambiado algo, pero Ruby
en la previa de la jornada 42 decía que
vamos, que no contaban con el para el playoff.
No, no, no.
Lo que decimos también,
que es que la Almería tiene jugadores de valor internacional.
Claro, el europeo Sub-21
para mí está por delante de un playoff
de segunda división.
A ver, esto es mucho más profundo.
Esto es mucho más profundo. Pero a nivel
de industria es muy complicado explicarle
a un aficionado que paga un abono y que
paga una pasta y está pagando a un jugador, que ese
jugador pone por delante
algo, un
fútbol que no le paga. Porque el
jugador luego quiere tener un Casoplón,
quiere tener dos cochazos y un jeff privado.
Pues eso no se lo da Colombia.
Eso se lo da el Almería,
el Wattfor, el Granada,
XXX. Bueno, pero cuando
viene el Atalanta y quiere pagar 30 kilos
por Pubil o 20 kilos, no me acuerdo
cuando ponían, en parte es porque
Pubil va a jugar los Juegos Olímpicos con la selección.
Es que
es ida y vuelta. Si no se puede
desligar, ya, pero te quiero decir que tiene mucho debate
eso de que el fútbol es más importante. Estos son
miradas. Tú eres uruguayo, para ti
lo más importante es Uruguay.
Es que no es que ni que tengas
razón ni que no la tengas. Es que los europeos
lo vemos de una forma muy diferente al
sudamericano. E insisto,
los españoles queremos llevar
razón y los latinos quieren llevar
razón. Pero es que no tiene razón nadie.
Tú con tu selección vas a jugar toda la vida en el
Almería. No sé cuando es
la media que pasa un fútbolista de Almería,
pero con suerte juegas 3, 4
temporadas. Que es lo normal.
Pero para llegar a la selección tenés que jugar en
el Almería. Y para mantenerte en el día a día
el Almería te tendrá que pagar su sueldo.
Y este sueldo tienes que ganar trabajando.
Si el Girona se juega un playoff de segunda,
el Girona se juega un playoff de segunda
y Uruguay llama a Estuani,
que es, le van a poner una estatua a la puerta del club,
Estuani va a la selección. Es que
yo creo que
está siempre como eso. No sé, no sé.
Me gustaría verlo, me gustaría verlo.
Llaman a Estuani para ser el suplente de Cavani
y de Luis Suárez y va.
Si te llaman para ser el suplente de Luis Suárez y
van a👇i對不對.
El segundo minuto
el vlogs de
Thais,
coño, no entres que con Anna horas
회
вы
мне
к Universe
que ha terminado inesperadamente... ¡muy bien!
¡Movido!
¡Hasta luego!
¡Calentito!